Alex: Wooo we are live and I am grinning like I found a bestseller hiding under a fake name! Welcome back to The Office 360 Unfiltered. I am Alex. Folks, tonight we are going into author world. A popular story so big it ate the bestseller list, ate the movies, ate your aunt's book club, and it started as Twilight fan fiction under a username that sounds like a frozen dessert. Snowqueen Icedragon. Come on! Stay with me. This is Episode Thirteen and we are going to talk.
Morgan: Ha I cannot stop laughing and I have the research in front of me. I'm Morgan. E.L. James, Erika Mitchell, a television executive in London, watches Twilight, reads Twilight, rereads Twilight. She writes Master of the Universe as fan fiction under Snowqueen Icedragon on FanFiction.net. Then she rewrites it, files off the serial numbers, and the world meets Christian and Ana in Fifty Shades of Grey. The biggest publishing rocket of that decade was hiding in a fanfic neighborhood like a mansion with no doorbell.
Alex: Come on, I love the details. She told the Chicago Tribune she watched the movie, read the books, reread them, had unpublished novels in a drawer, then found fan fiction. NPR later put it simply: Christian Grey began his fictional career as a vampire. There are no vampires in the rewrite and people still say wait, that was Twilight? Somebody loved a book so much they wrote in the margins of the culture until the margins became the mall.
Morgan: And then the receipts started vanishing. Galleycat and the Los Angeles Times reported Wayback Machine snapshots of the old site gone. The agent said yes it started as Twilight fan fiction, then she took it down and rewrote it. The American publisher told the AP that Master of the Universe and Fifty Shades were two distinctly separate works. If grandma cannot find the hardcover in three clicks, you are doing a Snowqueen without the movie deal.
Alex: This is where our studio lives. Authors come to The Office 360 with a book that could change a life and a homepage that treats the book like a secret. Three-click discoverability. Book. Store. Done. Fifty Shades found readers because people passed it like a hot dish, not because the original fanfic site was a cathedral of user experience. Word of mouth is a miracle. Your website should not require a miracle.
Morgan: Ha, and I have audited this. Publisher site, author site, Amazon tab, Instagram bio that says link in bio pointing to a link in bio. Funny because a frozen-dessert username built a global franchise. Heavy because a lot of you have the talent and none of the doorbell. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com, subject Story Time. Launch or reading: subject Shout Out. We got you covered.
Alex: Wooo I am still on the fanfic because the lesson is delicious. You do not control FanFiction.net. You do not control the Wayback Machine. You do not control an agency theme that owns your repo. Ownership. Keys. Four seniors, Lisbon to New York. Fixed scope. When the invoice is paid, the house is yours. Subscribe. Download. Tell one human. Preferably an aunt who already knows the plot.
Morgan: Mailbox, slow, for the back row. Story Time. Shout Out. Advertise. Donate. All of it theofficetechies@gmail.com. Listen all the way through. This one is long on purpose. Try to buy your own book on your phone with one thumb. If you get lost, you already know the punchline. theoffice360.com. Code STUDIO50. Fifty percent off the studio tiers.
Alex: Let me land it with joy. A TV executive falls in love with a vampire romance, writes in the margins, the margins become a planet, the receipts try to vanish, and somewhere a debut novelist has a gorgeous site where the cart is three clicks past a poem about fog. Authors, schools, churches, publishers. If your pretty page is FanFiction.net with a retainer, come see us. We build the doorbell. You own the house.
Morgan: Thank you for sitting in the long hour. I'm Morgan, he's Alex, this was The Office 360 Unfiltered, Episode Thirteen, the fanfic that ate the bestseller list. Email us. Story Time. Shout Out. Advertise. Donate. theofficetechies@gmail.com. Listen. Download. Subscribe. Tell an aunt. theoffice360.com. We love you. We got you covered. Go check your own link. Bye!